[Music]
in this video I'm gonna teach you how to
thrive in social situations we all have
those situations the certain situations
where we feel totally triggered by
certain people whether that be in work
or out of the pub or at a party wherever
it is there are certain people that
really know how to push our buttons when
we go into these situations the first
thing we want to do is close down and
run away or drink five wines and open up
and do something that we might regret in
the morning what if I told you that the
certain people that trigger you are
giving you an opportunity to grow in
some way what if these people provided
ideal situations for you to move on and
move through your anxiety or your
discomfort or your frustration or anger
or whatever emotions are coming up to
the surface in that moment I'd like to
teach you a tool that really helped me
and thousands of clients that I've
worked with over the years before you go
into a certain situation take a moment
close your eyes and visualize a seat in
front of you and imagine it inviting the
person that triggers you the most and
you may have a hit list here the person
that triggers you the most to come in
and sit on the seat in front of you
while this is happening observe what
kind of feelings and emotions and
tension and tightness start to arise up
in your body and sit with whatever is
coming up so you're visualizing a
situation that's going to happen ahead
of time with the person that triggers
you the most sitting opposite you and
you're witnessing the feelings and
emotions that come up
to the surface all these feelings and
emotions need to be experienced felt or
processed in some way so sit there for a
couple of minutes while everything's
coming up to the surface and breathe
into it after a couple of moments
guaranteed you will feel calmer more
connected to that person and less
stressed about seeing them in that
particular situation that you go to
another tool that helps me really well
in these situations is when I am walking
into a big social group that maybe I'm
meeting for the first time I start to be
aware of the thoughts that are telling
me to close down and run away and I
choose instead to do the very opposite I
choose to open myself up and walk
further into the crowd does that sound
crazy actually what happens is the very
opposite that you are afraid of
happening you are afraid of something
happening in that social situation that
might put you in a place of
vulnerability in some way actually what
happens when you open yourself up and
walk further into the crowd is that they
welcome you with open arms I look
forward to teaching you much more in the
following videos